"It was just like Groundhog Day."
This expression refers to the movie's theme of maddening repetition...
...and perfectly sums up the human habit of making the same stupid mistakes over and over again.
Groundhog Day concerns Bill Murray's character who is forced to live one day of his life...
...over and over again until he changes into a more compassionate person.
Imagine being asked, "What if there were no tomorrow?"
You might answer, "No consequences!"
If it were true you might embark on a wild night of reckless abandon,...
...knowing that the next morning things will be undone and you can start over.
Then ask yourself, "What would you do if you were stuck in one place,...
...and every day was the same and nothing you did mattered?"
Well, many of us behave in our jobs,...
...schools, or relationships just as if we were stuck in time.
The conclusion we might reach...
... is that life is what we make of it and that we can make each day special...
...or that we can waste time by becoming stuck in our routine.
Last, it has been said,...
..."For some a mistake is a lesson, for others it is a lifetime of the same lesson."
What if we were stuck in a continuous time loop...
....where we just made the same character driven mistakes over and over again.
Would we have enough sense to get off this treadmill and change our lives?